Rhianna is serving her dad court papers
guys this is fin t over family in this
case rihanna is suing her father Ronald
fin t and fin T Entertainment over
claims that he's using her brand and his
relationship to her to launch his own
business now in court Doc's obtained by
et the singer and beauty mogul is suing
for false advertising and a laundry list
of other things false designation of
origin violation of California Civil
Code invasion of privacy false light
publicity and she is seeking declaratory
relief and injunctive relief which
basically means she's not looking for
money here but she does want the court
to make a decision
ASAP in IC y et has learned Rihanna
claims her dad is seeking to profit off
the success of fin t beauty because he
is associated with the same last name
according to court documents have
fraudulently misrepresented that their
third party company fin T Entertainment
is affiliated guys it's not so there's
really a fine line to walk when you're
dealing with business and family and
maybe there should have been a combo
between RiRi and her dad on how they
could help expand the fin t brand with
her instead of with an outside party I
mean maybe there was a conversation we
don't know maybe this is all just the
results now the Barbados beauty is
taking it a step further they're
requesting more limits to be put in
place to protect her beauty Empire Court
docs state Rihanna is asking to keep her
dad and business partner from selling
advertising or promoting goods and
services using fin C's likeness or
anything that could make people think
that she is involved now it's no
surprise that Rihanna will want to
protect her brand since she's a 30 year
old self-made business owner I mean
she's worked really hard for this one
guys guys the limit no rule I could do
whatever I want about I want to where
you're making your own rules now aren't
you at the launch of fin t Beauty she
broke records with over seventy two
million earned media value and guys she
encouraged a movement in the beauty
realm causing her competitors to step
their game up when she offered 40 unique
foundation shades it was a lot guys and
here's what she had to say about it
this line you said it's very important
to you to create beauty for all women
why is that beer madam
Festo because all women deserve to feel
beautiful and all women deserve to have
a choice and an option when they go to
the makeup counter I don't think that's
fair to limit it to one shade or one
coupe shade I think you know I have
friends of all races all skin tones and
I think it's painful to exclude anyone
women love makeup and they should all be
included et has reached out to Finn T
Entertainment for comment rihanna is
also asking for damages and attorney
fees we will keep you updated with the
latest so be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time guys I'm
recording the underscore teza No
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]